a year ago there were stories people
would say was like well I knew someone
who was at that rally and they were
walking around the grass but they never
got charged or rest I thought they'll
show up at your house well and then they
just arrested Owen Troyer uh they had
arrested tomorrow they're trying to
sentence him to like what 120 days he
didn't go into the capitol he was
hanging out outside and part of the
thing and yelling and yelling generic
anti-establishment like revolutionary
commentary and then the sentencing well
I said I think it's a death retirement
yeah until the Democrats were tyrants I
mean yeah
they also referenced things that he said
on air yeah I mean
after yeah if you read the the statement
from the doj they say in the months
leading up and they said he he made
January 6th I mean they are trying to
make another person they're pinning this
on uh and you know rightly so his
attorney has responded with uh you are
trying to use to violate his Free Speech
rights and to make this more than what
it is they also say you know he's been
on pre-trial like it's supervised
pre-trial